Hey Evelyn, ich habe zwei Fragen an
dich,
du hast gerade in Deutschland schon zwei verschiedene Rollen bekommen,
weil
du laut Chart ein
bisschen
kindisch bist  Horrorfilme wie „The
Tomb Final Destination“ oder „Happy Tree
Friends“ mögen vor allem
tolle Grafiken und ich war sehr beeindruckt,
Final Cut Pro oder etwas Kreatives wie
dieses zu fusionieren. Es ist sehr cool. Ich habe viele
Freunde, die das tun. Das macht mir immer
Spaß  Okay, ich bin so hin und weg
von der großartigen Grafik, seine erste
Frage war: Oh, oh, die Figur, und wenn
es zu kindisch ist, denke ich, ist ein gutes Wort
für Lily, sie ist sehr kindisch, sehr
unreif, und ich habe das Gefühl, dass das letzte,
was großartig war, weißt du  Ich
konnte diese Figur so lange spielen, dass ich sie
irgendwie entwickeln und sie
von dieser kindlichen Figur zu einer vielleicht etwas reiferen Figur machen musste,
ich meine in der
letzten Staffel von Hannah Montana, die i
Ich strahle sie gerade aus. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Sie in
Deutschland vielleicht schon ausgestrahlt haben. Ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ob Sie wirklich sehen können, wie die
Charaktere, die Sie so lange kennen und mit
denen Sie aufgewachsen sind, wirklich
reifer geworden sind, und das sind sie  Im letzten Jahr
der High School haben sie feste
Freunde und feste Jobs und gehen aufs
College, und sie benehmen sich wirklich
erwachsener und entfernen sich von dem
ursprünglichen Bild, wer sie waren, nämlich
dass ich ursprünglich der erste
Staffelmann in Montana Lily war  war ein Skater-Mädchen
und wir haben all diese verrückten Klamotten
und jetzt ist sie irgendwie erwachsen geworden und ich erinnere mich,
dass ich eines Tages im Kleiderschrank nach oben ging
und der ausführende Produzent
oben im nächsten von Dalia
saß, der
unser Designer war, und er war so  Stopp, ich
liebe, was du trägst, und
ich habe nur geprobt, was auch immer du trägst,
und er meinte, wir müssten
genau deinen Stil für Lily machen, also haben sie für die
letzte Staffel von Hannah Montana
meinen eigenen Stil genommen und sich mit
dem c befasst  Charaktere damit wie kleine
Blazer und zerrissene Jeans und coole
Schuhe und so etwas, von dem ich denke, dass es
mein Stil ist, aber ich denke, am Anfang war
es ein bisschen kindisch, aber das war ich,
aber in der letzten Staffel flog ich eine
18  einjähriges Mädchen, also war es nicht
so schlimm und ich denke, das ist es, was
Disney sehr familienfreundlich ist,
und ich habe absolut kein Problem damit
, diese Art von Rollen zu spielen, natürlich
würde ich gerne
Endstation spielen  oder Doom was auch immer das ist, ich
denke, das würde Spaß machen. Ich hatte
nicht die Gelegenheit, ein
Gothic-Gothic-Girl und eine Art gruseliger
Film
zu machen  Rollen in verschiedenen Rollen und
alles, was ein historisches Stück ist, und wirklich
jede Art von Rolle, die sich irgendwie
von den Charakteren entfernt, wird
hauptsächlich gespielt, weil ich versuche, davon wegzukommen,
danke für die Antwort, gib es auf,
Grüße aus der Schweiz, ja  sagen, ich
mag es zu sha  das ist
sehr cool, das ist eine tolle Frage,
wenn es um die Schule geht. Ich
glaube fest an die Schule, aber ich träume
mein ganzes Leben lang von einem ziemlichen College, und es
war glücklicherweise immer die Nummer eins in
Hannah Montana, wo ich konnte  immer noch
eine Stunde von der Arbeit entfernt meine private High School zu besuchen,
und ich wurde manchmal schwierig,
weil ich drei Wochen im Monat nicht in der Schule war,
weil wir drei Wochen im Monat
an der Show arbeiteten
und ich nur in der Schule war
für ungefähr eine Woche hier und da und
ich musste all meine Arbeit
zwischen Proben und Dreharbeiten und langen
Stunden erledigen. Ich erinnere mich nur, besonders im
Juniorjahr Juni, das das härteste in
den Staaten
ist  Ich wäre einfach
überwältigt von all den übermäßigen
Mengen an Hausaufgaben, die ich
von meiner Schule hätte, und ich müsste sie mit nach
Hause nehmen und fertig machen, bevor
ich am nächsten Tag zum Schießen gehen
müsste, und ich müsste entweder meine Frau faxen  rk oder
schicke meine Arbeit ein oder bringe sie physisch zur
Schule, und es war so ein Schmerz,
und ich entschied mich ziemlich spät im Spiel
, zu einem unabhängigen
Studienprogramm mit einer Lehrerin zu wechseln, die erstaunlich ist
und sie, sie ist eigentlich lustig, mit der sie
arbeitet  diese YouTube-Sensation
Greyson Michael Chance, der das Lady-
Gaga-Cover gemacht hat, sie arbeitet jetzt mit ihm zusammen,
aber sie ist unglaublich und sie
hat mir wirklich aus meinem letzten
Highschool-Jahr herausgeholfen, und ich war acht. Ich habe ein
anderes Programm gemacht und konnte die
Klassen auswählen  dass ich wollte, dass ich es in
meiner eigenen Zeit machen könnte, weniger stressig und
tatsächlich fast lehrreicher, aber ich
hatte diese normale Highschool-Erfahrung,
die großartig war
sehr wichtig für
mich, ich werde nächstes Jahr aufs College gehen
und dieses Jahr kann ich offensichtlich nicht, weil
ich hier zu viel reise und das
College sehr anders ist. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass
ich tatsächlich physisch dort sein möchte  Ich bin fürs College
und ich bewundere wirklich Leute wie Emma
Watson, du gehst zur Brown University
und machst das ganze College-Ding, und ich
werde es hoffentlich schaffen, dass
ich am College angenommen wurde. Ich muss nur
warten, muss ein bisschen warten  Gute
Frage, bleib in der Schule, das ist wichtig